Act tough.
Be a man...
Well I don't know what you mean by that.
Unafraid.
Courage.
I feel it's kind of sexist when someone just says, "Be a man."
Well, there's strong women as well.
Strong.
Stupid.
It's almost a sexist phrase, too...
...like if you're not being a man, it's kind of saying you're being a woman in a way too.
Take responsibility.
Sexist.
It's a very accepted form of sexism.
To be the man, it implies that you need to be something specific.
Silly.
Relative.
Honest.
Being true to yourself and your surroundings, the people you work with,...
...the people you live with, the people you love.
Trust your instincts.
Be strong, don't let people push you around and be kind to women.